in the wind
donc là téléphone
je vais maintenant vous présenter serge
gainsbourg qui pour vous s'est mis à se
moquer ouais j'ai gagné mon pari
j'ai gagné mon pari voilà whitney
houston serge gainsbourg gainsbarre pour
les intimes
voilà assis debout serge dit plus que
vous l'avez trouvée sublime voilà serge
gainsbourg auriez vous demande comment
allez-vous baril va bien bien bien bien
super si ça marche de marché 2 aux mains
devant ses yeux regrette genius hisser
hors jean 105 me jean yole de mer
icéo agouazi dit que vous êtes très joli
ils se sont revus dinars yoann notre
reagan annoot courbettes kovatchev saut
du rail un highside à walker oui alors
je vais vous traduire non non non non
non icéo à regret il dit que vous êtes
très joli non non non non non non c'est
non non il a dit ça mais ça lui arrive
de 30 ans rien je peux pas vous traduire
ce qu'il a dit il a dit j'aimerais bien
vous auriez les fleurs pas du tout j'ai
dit jean réduire apaisé mais il a dit il
a des torts à pigalle
non non et non
il est normal vous imaginez quand il est
sous nom vous inquiétez pas huit mais
non il est gagné il est pas vraiment c
ou c en est anormal oui mais on va
maintenant ils super bien sûr qu'elle
est super presse à nouveau sombrer dans
l'es10 lopez of the beast présent tu tes
excuses en a six icônes du design
voilà il apologize il s'excuse il
s'excuse c'est un grand enfant
il aura pas de cigarettes cela ni ben
alors bon tu m'as convaincu les 10 on
retrouve eddy mitchell d'accord et je
signe mais oui oui d'accord jeudi offrir
à ses dires est ça va peut-être les
villes de côte il veut dire des bêtises
voilà qu'est ce qui m'arrive est
d'inviter gainsbourg encore tiens with
le phototype donné par dutronc sera là
en tout cas whitney houston
elle est prête d'oublier champs elysées
je dois vous dire venir lloris non oui
non savary soit hissé walter dix a fini
à des non notre sublime sublime c'est
mieux que super qu'est ce que je vais
dire maintenant ah bah oui je vais eddy
mitchell et michel et limoux